in my hero academia we haven't really
seen that much from heroes outside Japan
so in today's video we're gonna discuss
the number-one-ranked hero in the USA
captain celebrity now this guy made his
first appearance in the vigilante
spin-off manga and whereas all might
kind of reminds you of Superman Captain
celebrity is much more reminiscent of
this guy at least when we first meet him
when the series progresses you do
actually realize he's a good dude but
before we get into it I should warn you
that this video will have spoiled 4
vigilantes but the main focus of this
video is about his quirk his personal
life and its character growth as well as
why he came to Japan in the first place
so we're gonna be discussing those four
things and so any spoilers are directly
related to that and with that said let's
get into it
so captain celebrities real name is
Christopher skyline which is exactly the
kind of Mission Impossible sounding last
name you'd expect from America's top dog
now in most situations people simply
refer to him as Cece which is what I'll
be doing for the rest of the video as
it's just way easier CeCe's quark is
simply known as flight but that name
alone doesn't do it justice at a basic
level it gives him the ability to fly
around at high speeds as he's
demonstrated on many many many occasions
and following his first appearance in
Chapter 14 of vigilantes it wasn't until
chapter 46 that we found out the
secondary ability of his quark as it
says here this secret ability is kept
out of public knowledge so that people
can't figure out his weaknesses
essentially it gives him an invisible
barrier that wraps around his whole body
and protects him from physical harm and
also the temperature outside which is
why he was able to wear a skin-tight
sleeveless bodysuit during Christmas
time as he explains here the field of
protection can be extended to cover
other people but the more people he
protects were there the thinner it
becomes for him this was demonstrated
when he swooped in to save the three
little sisters from this explosion here
and unlike his usual invincible self
this time he actually suffered a lot of
blowback however this particular
incident despite his genuine heroism and
made him more popular than ever with the
video getting over a hundred million
views online with some commentators even
comparing him to all my too far guys too
far the last thing to mention about his
quirk is his incredible super strength
now it's never been explicitly stated
that this is the result of his flight
quirk but just to list a few of his
accomplishments he defeated what appears
to be Godzilla's long-lost cousin by
punching him in the face
he also lifted up a cruise ship and for
a time he was able to prevent the Tokyo
sky from falling with his bare hands
whilst being slammed into by these
kamikaze bombers which are basically
like prototype monomers that
self-destruct and to put this even more
into perspective the Tokyo sky air holds
about 50,000 people so you can imagine
just our heavy dares to support that
thing with just your two human arms
while his flight quirk assists him in
all these activities be strength that
he's putting on display is pretty
unnatural so either he's been drinking a
lot of protein shakes all his quote
gives him more power let me know which
one you guys think it is in the comments
below but I'm pretty sure it's his quirk
now moving on to his early years Cece
was incredibly popular in high school
so much so that he even had his own fan
club tell me one student in the current
series popular enough to get their own
fan club at school with the exception of
this guy I reckon you'd have a pretty
hard time finding one however while Cece
was adored by his peers there was one
person who pretty much refused to give
him the attention that he was so used to
and that was another student called Pam
throughout their first interaction she
scowled at him punched him in the face
made fun of his trademark smile and
equated him to a balloon meaning that
she thought he was hollow inside super
harsh stuff but SEC says it's just in
his personality that he wants everyone
to like him and he was always especially
popular with girls so the fact that
there was a girl who wasn't interested
in him really fascinated him and over a
period of time he was very very
persistent in trying to get her
attention as we can see in these panels
he was chasing her up until he became a
pro hero like that is some serious
commitment at least a few years now Pam
is someone who doesn't really think much
of other people and generally doesn't
like to show her true emotions but
eventually he was able to win her over
and as we see here they got married at
quite a young age but before we move on
to what else happened in his personal
life
let's briefly talk about his early hero
career and more specifically how old he
is now so in this panel it was stated by
President Mike that Cece had been top-10
material for 10 years running ever since
his debut now assuming that the US has a
similar hero system to Japan in that
heroes get their provisional licenses
whilst they're in high school and then
get their full licenses around the age
of 18 this would make CC roughly 28
years old when we first meet him in the
vigilantes manga and because this part
of vigilantes is about five or six years
before we meet deku in the main series
Cece is probably around 33 to 34 and
present-day so very close an age to
gentle criminal who is somehow only 32
this guy just he why does he look so old
the fact he was considered top-10
material ever since his debut puts him
in the same bracket as characters like
hawks in endeavor who were both top ten
heroes at very young ages and whilst he
was climbing up the American Hero
rankings who is having various troubles
at home to start with he says that he
always ended up making his wife mad and
this makes perfect sense because I'm
sure for those of you who are red
vigilantes you can tell this guy
constantly says inappropriate things
that are interpreted in different ways -
what he actually means we see this on
countless occasions with one especially
terrible example being when he referred
to another woman as a goddess when his
wife was standing literally right there
but he wasn't actually being flirtatious
he was talking from a professional point
of view another problem he had was that
he was being taken advantage of by
people he considered his friends as it's
implied that they sold stories about him
to the newspapers and on top of all of
that this one is probably the most
bizarre but he was actually sued by some
of the villains that he had taken down I
don't exactly know who's making the laws
in America that allowed that to happen
but yeah pretty weird stuff could you
just imagine how many times all might
would be sued if they actually allowed
things like this in Japan because of all
these incidents coupled with the fact
that he went on to have numerous
encounters with women other than his
wife he began to be referred to as
captain catastrophe celebrity most of
his legal troubles had to do with women
and when he makes his debut in
vigilantes it stated that Pam is seeking
reparations for all his cheating this
brings us to the reason why he finds
himself in Japan in the first place so
Cece had his hero license revoked in
certain states due to the mountains of
lawsuits against him and so he went to
Tokyo to make a living there instead his
first appearance saw him save queeg's
life as he was about to be splattered by
an oncoming truck now kuchi is the main
character in the vigilantes manga by the
way and following this Cece was
horrified to know that cuicci didn't
know who he was then going on to sign
his all my hoodie much Tuukka which he's
discussed as his level of admiration for
all might would rival even Deku or
night.i
Cece made his next appearance by taking
down this Godzilla creature but what
made this moment especially hilarious
was the fact that he refused to start
helping before the media had fully set
up so that they could capture his
heroics and also because he wasn't
legally obligated to help until the
police and
former request there's no way you can
convince me that that's not something
homeland er would say in that same
fiasco he also saved cuicci from being
crushed by a falling rock but again it's
interesting to note that when presented
with two civilians to save from a
collapsing building he opted for the
woman despite the fact that his super
strength would have been more suited to
saving the sumo wrestler rather than
leaving it to koishi and his spaghetti
arms now one of the many reasons why I
love CC as a character is due to his
epic growth throughout the series he was
introduced to us as arrogant reckless
overly flirtatious and someone who's
just not in it for the right reasons one
example is when he went to a restaurant
with Makoto and what she told him of a
bank robbery that was going down his
exact reply was who cares about that all
that matters is our time together I mean
I guess it's romantic but you wouldn't
catch a true hero saying that however in
this situation he did eventually sort
out the whole robbery thing after
realizing that Makoto and Pam were in
contact and that if he was to cheat
again whilst in Japan his wife would use
it as evidence in her many many lawsuits
against him this then led to him picking
cuicci up off the street and pretending
as if he was entertaining a couple of
fans rather than going on what he
thought was a date under Mercato's
leadership as his manager sees he was
incredibly busy during his time in Japan
consistently booking him a parish's
photoshoots interviews in addition to
his hero work basically he had no time
to do anything else except his job and
he built up a lot of good connections
including with fellow heroes like
Ingenium and look he even got all my
wearing as much his relationship with
kiichi mainly consisted of saving his
life on numerous occasions something
which he actually made a point to say
that he was tired of doing however by
the end of his arc in this series he was
willing to sacrifice his own life just
that kawiti would live and he used what
was left of his barrier to shield koishi
and save him from a fall luckily all
might showed up and saved them both as
well as 50,000 other people and I'm sure
Bridge nineties readers would agree with
me when I say that this was one of the
best displays of all might speed that
we've seen but going back to CC he
didn't really go after any girls during
his stay in Japan and he became a legit
selfless hero eventually he was able to
go back to the US as his hero license
was restored in all the states because
many of the lawsuits against him
actually amounted to entrapment of some
kind so it's likely the
was setup on more than one occasion he
also turned out that Pam was pregnant
before he left to go to Japan and had
decided to raise the baby on her own
until Cece was in the right place to
raise a child and as it turns out by the
end of his stay in Japan he was more
than worthy of fulfilling that role as
he and Pam got back together happy days
and that my friends is captain celebrity
explained as you can see he's actually a
pretty cool character and although far
from perfect he's clearly tried hard to
be a better person he's yet to make an
appearance in the main series but if
Deku and the gang ever visit America
whether that be for a potential third
movie or maybe just an arc in the manga
then it would be great to see what Cece
is up to in the present day especially
as his son would now be at the age where
he's manifesting his quirk now that
could be interesting make sure you sub
to the channel and if you're interested
I didn't able to view of the first arc
of vigilantes which will hopefully ease
you into the series not sure what I'm
gonna do a follow-up to that but I will
say that there's a vigilantes list video
that is not too many weeks away thanks
for watching guys peace out
you